greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happen now is brought to you by
manscaped the best and the men's below
the belt
grooming listen guys ladies christmas is
coming and if you want to slide down her
chimney or his chimney you got to get in
manscape you got to be prepared for war
they created the only thing you need to
shave your balls it's called the
lawnmower 2.0 for a reason ladies you
could trim your monkey with this - it
won't hurt and if you're a guy and you
date another guy and you take it I'm
saying I'm just trying to help you out
here for the holidays listen 2.0 it's
tremendous it's perfect for travel easy
to charge and you can some manscape
wherever you are and you could do a one
hand in the other hand you can watch
porn on your phone I don't know what to
tell you listen please are we're going
to do the church listeners get 20% off
your first order when you use promo code
church at manscape calm and if you order
the perfect package don't throw in a
free travel bag when you use code Church
CH you are CH that's manscape doc tom
the church is also brought to you by
it's a whole new year people you want to
be healthy or not athletic greens you
got one month before the new year
athletic greens it will help you get
there if you're starting you if you're
not starting your day off with a blast
of vitamins you already lost a war go
back to bed [ __ ] something that
said it's over but if you want to feel
tip-top Magoo let athletic greens do the
dirty work they got you covered in five
critical areas health energy immunity
guts health and a hormonal support so
right now the church family you got a
special offer I'm gonna hook you up with
20 free travel packs valued at $79 with
your first purchase jump over to
athletic greens comm slash Church that's
athletic greens dot-com slash Church
another unusual gift for the holidays
because everybody's got one and
everybody stinks a portable birthday you
like joy what's a portal birthday you
look it up on your toilet you hook it up
to the piping outside so it's not even
using toilet water choosing this
the same water you brush your teeth with
and then it sprays your ass and removes
the poop [ __ ] toilet paper so you're not
walking around all day with bacteria at
least the nasty things like hemorrhoids
yeast infection UTI itchy ass holes and
skid marks it's all over right start
2020 with a clean ass I'm telling you
right now
they started $79 go - hello - ChiCom
slash Church and get 10% off your order
kick this [ __ ] muley that's real
that is real [ __ ] real this song
drives me [ __ ] nuts Alonzo Bodden
what's the story what's up Joey shut up
with your clip pushing too long you know
I'm gonna represent in the Church of the
Lamb you know I'm gonna represent in
church I yelled a ton last week was the
best because it really pisses me off
Alonzo when you came on the first time
you showed me I forgot what it was to be
a fan again I really did bro yeah well
it was to go to a baseball game with a
glove right actually think you were
gonna catch a ball yeah I said a little
knick game with a basketball and why
would you take a basketball to it that's
how I started gambling on sports yeah
and you look at sports as something
different now so know that you don't
gamble you don't hold much sports and
you lose that you lose that you know
like when you watch college basketball
and you see that kids paint their face
you know and you're saying I'm gonna
look at that [ __ ] ass I'll [ __ ] you
no man it's having the best day of his
[ __ ] life that kids yet it's the best
day of his life especially college ball
the thing I love about college ball
every game counts and they're not pros
yet like they still make mistakes but
like you said they're playing their ass
off they their heart is in the game and
and they really do believe it you know
it it's a business now right college
ball is a billion-dollar business with
the tournament and all of that but to
the kids plan there's still some level
where they're playing for Seton Hall
they're playing for Carolina they're
playing for whatever school you know
what I mean like that yeah they're they
leave it all on the floor I love college
ball I love
the effort the effort because that's
what it is all-out effort and yeah I
started watching sports again little by
little drips and drabs you know little
baseball
I watched the finals you know Kwame
[ __ ] I love that style of Bastet what
he plays so I watched that I watched the
World Series football this year's just
[ __ ] atrocious except for three teams
yeah I don't watch the NFL needs to do
something that's Street I think well I
don't know the NHL enough to speak on it
but for basketball baseball football the
NFL needs to like that I don't know what
they need to do I need to clean up the
act they need to make the game something
they'd you know like football is better
on TV than life like like the whole
thing is designed to be a TV spectacle
right and and if you're playing defense
for a few years now you couldn't touch a
quarterback now the defensive backs are
like well what's past interference like
what do I do
I gotta let him cut I can't touch him
but then when he catches a ball I still
can't hit him because he's defenseless
imagine telling ronnie Lott that he
couldn't hit a defenseless receiver
ronnie Lott used to let him catch the
ball just so he right just so he could
kill him he was like yeah you'll catch
one and then for the rest of the day
you're just here in my footsteps right
remember that we used to talk about that
footsteps and yeah we we got we know
about the concussions now and molester
and this and that yeah let's the
molester used to get you ass he used to
spray stick them all over here remember
that they had that low stance off the
line and [ __ ] so I don't know what
they're gonna do with football I know
they're trying to make it an offensive
game I'd given up on football for a
while now I'm starting to watch it again
but it's I don't have a team I don't
have a team near do I I mean I like
watching the you know because it's
perfect football I like watching New
England cuz it's perfect football I grew
up watching
check in Lawrence Taylor so the wing was
an extension of that
yeah like watching Danny and Asano teach
kung fu he's teaching Bruce Lee kung fu
but I think about the NFL in the next 20
years how hard it's gonna be it's gonna
change because of football because not
everybody's putting their kid in the
football almost his parents aren't
letting their kids play football
even in my hometown which was built on
football yeah no not now listen I know a
lot of mothers who are like no my kid
ain't playing football
plain and simple like my kid is not
gonna get hit you know they got a deuce
it's a line it is a violent game but
they got to figure out how to keep the
game exciting but still protect the
players you know protect their heads
right I'd the best thing I heard but
it's crazy as it sounds the best idea I
heard it was a doctor whose neurologist
she said go back to leather helmets he
said because if you're wearing a leather
helmet you won't use your head for a
weapon which you know made sense right
because part of the reason they started
using that the helmet is because the
helmet is so strong so I don't know they
they got to they got to do something
with the game because right now it's so
heavily weighed on the offense that the
defense I think they're like well what
do we what do we do
right what do we do we can't hit the
quarterback we can't hit the receivers
what do we do but but part of the game
and and I'm not saying taking people out
like like you know we're not talking
1978 Raiders but the game is somewhere
between that and and where we're headed
now it won't go away for you know why
football won't go away cuz it's a number
one you talked about gamblin umber one
gambling sport in the country right more
money's bet on the Super Bowl than any
event we have so it's not gonna go away
because that money ain't going away
what's gonna happen is though it's gonna
change the college
more african-american Latino kids people
watch the report I think I'm real Sports
is what's going on right now that
they're the ones that are picking up the
slack couple Jews in you know if you got
no money to go to college this is your
answer
yeah it's the way in so they don't give
a [ __ ] they're like this is your way in
we'll figure it out I said here at times
you think that this just come from the
[ __ ] sky all these concussions and
all this PTSD I want to know that about
those guys that were playing with
leather helmets
what was that percentage CIA you know I
started watching football in the 70s
with Pittsburgh Steelers that that was
the team you watched if you are a
violent person yeah crazy and yet I
fearsome foursome yeah and all that yeah
I love that [ __ ] I love the Raiders and
I loved it and that's you know you're
Cuban there's no baseball you're angry
you might as well get see somebody we
get [ __ ] hit from behind you know we
also Lawrence Taylor break
what's-his-name's legs yeah anyway no
the hits used to be part of football and
it used to be two highlights one app
right those guys I know that well a long
time Center from the Pittsburgh stem
cell Webster blew his head off his head
off junior say I'll killed himself that
was a big deal I was a big deal but but
this is the thing and this is a
different time we're living it so those
players from the 70s you know why we
don't know what happened to because we
didn't have social media we didn't have
24/7 access so like once you retired
from football if you weren't an
announcer you just went away right so we
have no idea what I know a lot of those
guys did die young a lot of football
players died in their 40s and 50s and
they said because of the collisions like
they said if your alignment right
offensive defensive linemen it's like
being in a car crash cuz they just bang
into each other's bodies and their
internal organs would get messed up and
but but again nobody cared cuz nobody
knew right so we're only finding this
now because we have we have the
information now we know what happens to
a player 10 years 15 years after his
career but I'm sure if you went back and
looked I bet a lot of those players from
the 70s you know were whacked out in the
80s and he's a like boxers like I
watched you know a couple weeks it was
an interesting fight Mazda Valle against
Diaz and it got stopped because of a cut
that people argued they thought two will
last and two days later I was on line
and I saw Roberto Duran versus Davey
more I clicked on the fight it's one of
my all-time favorite fights I haven't
watched in about four years Roberto
Duran since 32 year old on his way out
fighting a 26-year old beast who's 16
and now and Roberto Duran unleashes a
beating on this man that it is just
horrifying it's horrifying to watch as a
spectator even if you like boxing yeah
there's a couple times where the
announcers are going stop this [ __ ]
his fight this poor guy is knocked out
standing up Roberto was not hitting him
knocking him out my head and I'm waking
him up and and I said look how different
boxing was in the 70s
look at the garden well you would have
stopped that fight in the garden that
night they would have killed you yeah
they're gonna throw in chairs cuz I
remember the garden they throw chairs
they used to love Patrol those [ __ ]
chairs and you look at the dirty forty
indifference how they stopped it over a
cut under the eye and I wasn't there
looked like a serious cut it was a cut
that been open from previously from the
fight before blah blah blah but still it
was like we didn't give a [ __ ] in the
70s no well that's I mean but that's
good for the athletes right because they
did they were warriors and the other
thing about boxing back then 15 rounds
right that's a long fight
think about that 15-round fight that
last three rounds they you know how beat
they were by then you know what I mean
it's it's every sports different now
every sports different now but but the
physical the violence board even hockey
right they didn't wear helmets man you
didn't hit with a hockey puck you know
what I'm saying like it's only recently
hockey head helmets right and then they
call them [ __ ] for wearing helmets
you ever get checked but no I never
played I never played that oh I tried
that street hockey I went to Tom McCann
I bought my luan HL sneakers and [ __ ]
remember Tom McCann you stop now yeah
yeah is it so you would have to have the
NHL sneakers I bought my lawn HL
sneakers I went over their door they
slammed me against a Cadillac that was
it like that was it and then I saw some
kids head go through a glass room going
on at the same hockey and these kids
were serious like block against block
look up a guy Ryan Reeves it's my boy he
plays for he plays for Vegas he plays
for the Golden Knights look up his
highlights greatest hits that's he's
that guy he's you know in hockey they
got that guy who's just an enforcer
right yeah but they call them rot Revo
this guy knocks the [ __ ] out of people
like that that's basically his job you
know but yeah I never played but Manny
and because they're coming at you fast I
go on ice they gots Nate on ice skates
yeah I can't even [ __ ] walk and then
throwing and it's just part of the game
that's the crazy part it's just part of
the game yeah that they're badass is
that that's a that's you know it's tough
way to make a living you know even being
a kid once a week there was a nice
little misunderstanding and they
everything understand when the ABA I
think yeah I think it started like the
ABA was just wild the ABA was just wild
man this guy Marvin bad news bond yes
Roy you know I don't know how many times
he took a pistol out the pistol at the
garden they called
five hundred one time it's your mother
gaming cuz I'll be right back I'll be
right back I got a good laugh our Willis
Reed beat up everybody if you like food
drive as well as Reef yeah that body
that's like that's like him the Charles
Barkley's cousin well yeah who mystery
could be Charles Barkley's cousin he
could be Darryl Dawkins commend Willis
replayed like he couldn't walk like he
couldn't walk but he played come to that
basketball camp I loved yeah I loved
Willis Reed I love them huh yeah it was
basketball camp I told him like maybe
two times I gotta don't kid there for a
week and [ __ ] Darryl Dawkins chocolate
thunder
you know Willis Reed was only six foot
yeah what I mean only six six nine maybe
somehow he would listen he would have
picked them Shaq and slam dunk them
that's not crazy Willis Reed was I think
Moses would have killed Shaq and in
their prime it's a tough one nuts pricks
now come on Moses was gone twenty Moses
was gone 24:20 a night yeah Moses was
getting twenty and twenty absolutely but
Shaq when Shaq was playing I'm talking
about there was a bunch of Bambi's I'm
talking about when Shaq was in no but
Shaq made him look like that no I'll
tell you the one because I saw this okay
he played they played Portland remember
Kevin Duckworth all he was terrible
but he was huge he was huge Shaq moved
him with one arm like Shaq cleared this
guy had to be what six ten he claimed
270 so he was probably three of us he
casino
you know when Joe Pesci hit that guy in
the head with the fountain there's him
to the side he moved him he moved them
with one arm like he cleared out I he
was struggling you know so hey Maddie
Isaac Oh his fan I'm surprised you're
going for Shaq no no I listen no oh
watch Shaq was a physical specimen like
there was nothing like it was like when
wilt hit the Li like when will
Chamberlin hit the NBA there
never been anyone like they were like
you can't be that big and that's strong
and that fast you know what I mean and
and there was nothing they could do and
I think Shaq would have been the same
way now it would have been tougher if
Shaq had to play late seventies early
eighties would have been a tougher gig
but a tougher it would have been a
tougher gig because he because every
night you were going up against a body
you were going up against somebody you
know and he's getting like you said Joey
these guys came from street ball with it
day one did what Nexus foot night white
guy there wasn't at me that rule not
gonna push it
it wouldn't shatter wasn't that many
rules town you know Kalin was tough they
were tough man they were tough the game
dude hey hey stop limit ASA
he played with freckles just Lee Charles
Oakley is what 50 now yeah still scary
you still wouldn't want to get Nolan
threw him out of the garden and everyone
booed Yolen they asked him to leave yeah
yeah cuz he was behind Dolan talking
[ __ ] but oak I mean like you talk about
someone's named fitting them oak yeah he
was a tree and when he was in the paint
you knew it you know that this is the
big difference in NBA now right like so
now you have all these shooters and
scores but you don't have you can't play
physical defense you know we we've
talked about this before on the show
when you went up against the Knicks they
wanted to hold you to 60 points right
Oakley Mason and Ewing like like ass
Reggie Miller what it was like playing
against the Knicks you got hit every
time you know you did not come in to
paint without getting murdered the other
night Detroit against Chicago and they
just want to have to join oh yeah oh
yeah Chinese food no more yeah that [ __ ]
it it made him better made them better
and made our better there were teams
that when you went in there you paid
you paid yeah what a couple guys that
got you know but before I forget worse
three [ __ ] centers
okay like like these are guys that were
like like off-color okay and that's who
you played against when when Moses in
the long play he put it against artists
artis Gilmore he played against Bob
Lanier yeah
he played against there was Santa's
problem yeah
don't the Sun the center was a different
position about different position back
then and I thought I think that and I
know a lot of people hate on me for this
I think Shaq had it easy
I think Shannon easy I think Shaq had
Bambi down in San Antonio he was Bambi
dog oh you talking about the Admiral
yeah he was a nice guy
no but but again but you see you could
you could make the same argument with
Jordan right because the day and make no
mistake I'm not saying Jordan I seem
great but all right King covered Jordan
but here's his but he had AI competition
Jordan didn't have a direct competitor
right so you had magic and bird if
either one of them didn't have to go
against the other they would have won
six championships who had to go against
each other every you know what I'm
saying every year and then you had
LeBron who never had to team around him
if LeBron had a Scottie Pippen and you
know what I mean if he had the team
Chicago head then LeBron would have won
six you know and it this isn't the
Jordan people say this is a knock I'm
not knocking Jordan what I'm saying is
sometimes you get right place right time
and he always had a great team around
dog in college he had a great and me
beam around he was a freshman he had a
[ __ ] team er
worthy college worthy I forget the rest
I just remember Jimmy black him was it
Jimmy back yeah but it was worthy steam
that's what we forget it was worth least
and I did a charity thing with worthy
right and and it was great so um he's
got his wife
this is his second wife she didn't know
him when he played and I said oh you
never said she's an I said you should
have seen
his first step she said everyone says
that everyone mentions his yet where
these first step he was gone it was the
quickest it was like where to go but
worthy had to go up against Walter Davis
yeah and his it cocaine snorting as well
they had to end it they had to play
against Ewing they had him play I guess
David Thompson yeah they had a David
Thomas David Toms 54 Dania fell down the
stated Thompson could leap out of the
gym like before it was annoying eight
inches before it was a thing David
Thompson was what he was he North
Carolina State in the 70s or something
like that or I want to say he was at NC
State and I said but he could Walter
Davis Walter Davis Davis was Caroline
Caroline Davis went to Carolina but
David Thompson could leap and even you
know and you talk about the 70s dr. J
with that ABA ball habit let me tell you
Joey
you cut that fro cuz the fro was not
aerodynamic about the role of arrow that
the fro and made the man aerodynamic doc
would I mean and again it there's a
great book you love this book matter of
fact I've I just get this for you for
Christmas called loose balls this story
in the ABA and it's all the old ABA
players talking about when they were in
ABA you know Doug Moe and Rick Barry and
dr. J you know George Gervin right the
ice rink for the I 2018 and it was crazy
but that do from Detroit I mentioned
rain from Bad News bonds great bike
sixth grade teacher John Barone yeah the
guy you met play out of Miami Florida
ins you know but yeah dr. Jay man when
doc took off John Williamson when he
took off from the free-throw line and
did that windmill with that red white
and blue ball in his hand people do not
know that was it and that was that would
he what when he was with the Kentucky
Colonels you know I didn't know him that
that was what nobody knew Lilly Pope's
nobody knew Billy pulls and yeah I think
Keenan was his teammate on the Kentucky
kernel on the Kentucky kernel Larry
Keenan was real
Rick berry was the only guy who went
from the NBA to the ABA he went he went
backwards but he won it would Golden
State yeah he won it with Golden State
then he went to the ABA and it had to do
with coaches and old friends or
something I know we were we were talking
about like racism before and all that
stuff was there because I was just
thinking I know that there was a Negro
League for baseball was there any sort
of league like that for basketball
no no basketball the ABA and the ABA was
young young young gun hip-hop leaked
know you know when basketball changed
when well it's at Texas Western
University beat Kentucky it's a famous
college game so Kentucky's got this
coach Adolph Rupp old-school racist I'll
never have a black player on my team and
an all-black team lit him up beat him
for the championship and that was when
that was when the color line dropped
that oh you know these Negroes are kind
of good look at that boy right making
that 20-footer
yeah that was that change that that's
when but I the NBA the NBA didn't have
it wasn't as because the Lee came along
later and you had you had Bill Russell
right Bill Russell you know ten
championships so they date the NBA knew
like we're gonna let we're gonna get
these black guys playing we want to win
well the NBA was having a hard time
there it was it was a slower paced and
the ABA was you know Julius Erving the
ABA was was Street bottom run coming
home and having the red white and blue
ball and I still remember when he
[ __ ] when they collapsed and he
signed with the Sixers I stormed in at
night like it was yesterday and he was a
went for the number 32 to number six cuz
they paid him 6 million yeah that was a
lot of money that raised that money
right now pissed he kind of got 892
million dollars an hour but all of them
that that's true fall at ball play what
it was when Julius Erving was running
he changed my life I want the two of is
you had to buy a pair of Converse
limousines for the feet and you had to
have a ticket a golden lottery ticket
and I had a store a sneaker store and he
would take the ticket out for me
he saw coach cons which you weren't
allowed to wear you know them but you
got a beatin there was $7.99 and then
the Chuck whatever Chuck Taylors with
999 mmm but you gonna show up with the
coach cons that was a beating his [ __ ]
so then they went through limousine at
her feet yeah and then he had his first
so this is all paid for by Congress yeah
you would show up on a Saturday at 8:00
in the morning the first one was at
Fordham University Julius Erving pulled
up with his Mercedes we were all
standing on the line like little [ __ ]
that we were waiting to see Julius
Erving he got out with his son and he
came into the auditorium you brought us
in he did a seminar on shooting then he
made this all clap and he ran from one
side he jumped from the [ __ ] foul
line and that was the end of the seminar
yeah and then I went to see him at CCNY
he did two of them.that here [ __ ]
tremendous man that was my childhood I
love ya God Julius Erving not all lowing
my house I gotta bring a picture in here
I got two great pictures of him one
orders basketball player in there in
line saying I don't know if we can see
him or not no no I got Julius at the
house Lee gave me uh my friend Timmy
Holloway gave me the statue of Julius
and it's on my [ __ ] whatever okay but
not to a lighter note because I had to
actually come and do a podcast about
what you said to me that night we were
doing what's-his-name show and Eddie if
was talking about the Joker the Joker
and a bomb or whatever you know I
haven't seen the movie yet so and then
you chimed then when you watch The Joker
as a comic you could really see this
happening with a comic yeah cuz of all
the highs
and lows that we go through you know
like I mean right now what a ravaging
like we'll lose them one comic a year
comic every year just suicide which is
yeah bad others we've lost to suicide
only disguises something out right drugs
or whatever whatever but love it the
reason I said that is because and you
know to life right so we got the highs
and lows right like i like i joked about
it this is absolutely true i was on a TV
show Monday and that Friday Liz at the
VFW in Riverside California you know
what I mean but but then the other thing
is and this was even more what happened
to the Joker you watch people around you
get it and you don't they're moving up
as you're either sitting or moving down
or falling off or any of that and you
you gotta have you know that's why I
think beyond anything in this business
you got a love doing this because if
you're in it like if you just say well I
gotta make the money
or I gotta have the the followers that
you know the million followers on
YouTube or Twitter or or or the gram or
something like that if Fame is your only
incentive the odds are stacked against
you tremendously and emotionally I mean
let's be honest man we're all caught up
in this [ __ ] on different levels
emotionally you know what I mean like I
I had a therapist say to me one time she
saw me do this benefit and she said if I
could get you to be that guy on stage
all the time you'd be fine right because
when I'm on stage I'm bulletproof like
that night it was what was it two
Sundays ago or whatever and and you know
here's the thing we're following Joey
and and it you got to work
I got a but the beautiful thing about
you on stage is you are completely wrong
you are completely wrong is no there's
no I'm gonna be nice about this
I'll clean this up or I'm not gonna say
this right you say wherever you are in
the moment what do you know whatever
you're talking about it's you right it's
raw well we all do that onstage to
different extents right so when somebody
doesn't like you on stage
that's a very personal thing when you
put yourself out there now in the movie
- Joker he got he got really deep into
who he was and it was really bad you
know what I mean so so takes unit you
know what I mean it'd be like like
somebody bombing on a most personal note
but just watching it and watching the
deterioration I was like yeah this could
be any comic like if a comic was a
serial killer right nobody would be like
oh yeah he was a quiet guy oh now we saw
this [ __ ] coming right I mean that's not
all of us to to to that extreme but what
I'm saying is if you watch the movie and
you watch a deterioration and if you're
a comic you can see that happening
because this this says so much it is
that you got to be careful not to
believe right you gotta you gotta be
careful not to to believe all that you
know you can't believe Hollywood come on
Joe you've been in this you know longer
than me right I've I've always told
people like I never got a job from
someone who loved me oh man we love you
we love big fan blah blah blah yeah
exactly you don't get to work from that
love don't do nothing you don't you know
you get the work on somebody who's
somebody who wants to work with you they
make you an offer they don't tell you
they love you they make you an offer
they call your agent they put you on
avails when you said the highs and the
lows that night I was driving home and I
thought about the lows of this career
and times that I didn't you know I
didn't see but for me it was always a
day yeah for me it was always that day
like I tell comics all the time if you
really do what you're supposed to be
doing the universe will give you the
sign everything
that is to stay at this yeah the
universal time I can I can remember
those I remember those if you really
really really get in there get the
shovel put your head back and go this is
what I'm going for every 90 days the
universe should be throwing you
something
to give you an incentive to stay in this
game world as there's so many lows the
first five years you got to get on stage
see that's what destroys you cuz you you
have that bad set right you bomb now if
you're if you're new and you're hustling
and you're getting on stage three four
times a week anywhere anywhere you know
your bowling alley bar back of a coffee
shop or something then you can bounce
back if you're only working once a week
once every two weeks when you bomb
that's in your head for that long oh and
and that's the that's that's why people
give up that's why people give up right
because if you're if you just have that
in your head and you don't get another
chance you know I like him like in a
joker right he he screws up as a clown
and he gets fired
well now you never get to redeem
yourself from that so now you got to
live with that you failed but what like
we failed I felt at this 10,000 times
yeah but you succeeded 10,000 times to
how do you think you got good sets what
would happen in the Joker he didn't have
any good he had done good yeah he didn't
you you had good sets following bad sets
you had those those moments of success
leading my car right I [ __ ] you know
borrowed money from people I I did
triple you know you look at all the
great yeah it was a movie with [ __ ]
Adam Sandler and Clint Eastwood whatever
his [ __ ] name is Burt Reynolds and
yeah I got the
do something for Netflix and you look at
all these bright spots but that night
when you said that to me it made me tap
in to the dark side you know I got
sometimes at night I take a ride and I
on the way back from the store I go on
Lancashire but I hook a left on Magnolia
and I look at that bus station and bus
station is closed but there's still two
people standing there that are waiting
for a bus it's coming in 6:00 in the
morning now if these people had 20 bucks
they go to the diner it's down the block
they don't have 20 bucks there you have
to sit there till 6:00 the more you
think about how bad their life is and
right I still remember being you know
taking a bus from Miami to Buffalo and
you know stopping him between stops and
taking two hits off a joint but not good
and put switching batteries on my
Walkman or whatever the [ __ ] it was my
iPod I don't know what the [ __ ] it was
you know you think of all those sleeping
on couches but you know what Joey even
when we were doing that what gave us the
love because we love goin wallet cuz it
for me I've always loved doing it I've
always told people that the comedies not
to work right like you talk about
Tribble runs and stuff like that right
where I was a middle act okay so on a
good night you make fifty bucks right
and you literally drive from like
Tuesday is comedy night at the Holiday
Inn in Mesquite Nevada and then
Wednesday is comedy night at the
Radisson and you know Ames Iowa or
whatever the hell right and then
Thursday night is is comedy night at the
at the Dubuque Holiday Inn right and you
wished remember think about this
remember when you wished you could work
on a weekend remember that used to wish
you could work on the weekend now when
do you have a weekend off unless you
schedule it you won't have a we you
could you could work every weekend and
every weekend but there was a time when
our work week was Monday to wednesday
and you might get the Thursday Sunday
to third Sunday right Sunday Thursday
thank you could open it but Friday
Saturday you know yes sets if you were
lucky we look but but you love to me
I'll speak for me I love doing it so I
didn't think about being at the rest
stop sleeping or literally are just like
you said being broke or borrowing money
or hustling it was a hustle it was a hug
your daytime my daytime was a hustle
for my comedy now I was fortunate that I
had a few good jobs like I was a driver
for the kids show Power Rangers right so
yeah so that was a good job cuz on a
driving day you make a couple of hundred
bucks but I also painted addresses on
curves for five bucks a house and they
didn't have to pay you like you painted
it and then you went to the door and see
you get five bucks for doing it you know
I did that here in LA yeah yeah I did
that I hung televisions in in 7-elevens
for the [ __ ] lotto game right 40
bucks a set
no she climb up inside the roof of a
7-eleven and you mount a TV yeah right
there but that was that was the hustle
man that's what you did so and I did it
because I love conquers I never had any
doubt that comedy was what I was gonna
do it's crazy I never had an [ __ ]
cigars on the phone right what's a
garden how you doing my name is Joey did
you what's your name Mohammed
okay let me ask you some more how many
people going in looking for a cigar
every day I don't want to talk right now
you have to call back tomorrow and ask
for Mohammed - okay they got a call
tomorrow's Mohammed do that number three
you have looking for Mohammed Rita to
call back tomorrow then you finally get
Mohammed and you sell them a [ __ ]
humidor that's work you Tom I thought 12
hours worth of cigars not growing a
humidor and that was it one cigars maja
1998 that's how you met living
when Joey can't totally what do you what
do you guys were talking about to me it
made me realize how close people could
be to that but what I think the
difference is at least this is my
opinion is you guys had something
positive in the Joker and I think people
there's a lot of people like that or
just it is negative upon negative that
piles on ice no people in this town that
can't catch a [ __ ] break that's what
I was glad I feel [ __ ] terrible for
them
I know 20 people in this town right now
they cannot get arrested I check in on I
check in on from time to time i back
talk to a chick that was [ __ ]
homeless three weeks ago doing comedy
homeless homeless asked me if she could
take a shower here am I told anything to
have a shower yeah I only had a toilet
I'm sorry I can't help you you know and
she had to wait till nine o'clock at
night to sleep on her friend's house but
she told me she goes I'll go to the
[ __ ] park
I gotta catch the spot up in Canoga Syme
with it so right there I knew the chick
was on the up-and-up well when your
heart and soul right it doesn't matter
when your heart and soul is in something
and you don't get it
see that's the thing when whenever you
put everything in and like you said this
it's true for whatever reason some
people can't catch a break can't get it
end and they put in just as much work
they just put they put their heart and
soul in and some of them unfortunately
there are some people who don't have the
talent right you don't have the talent
and I'm gonna just stop in comedy I'm
talking whatever you want to do whether
it be music or acting or whatever thing
but you put everything into it that can
easily destroy you that's that's how you
you know like you said the sad thing is
the suicide alcoholism the drugs that is
it at the slow suicide that's the worst
that's the worst the slow suicide drink
yourself to death over X number of years
or whatever the hell you know and the
road gives you all the opportunities to
do that I proudly gives you the road
doesn't even have responsibility anymore
none what are they three three got 20
radio stations left yeah and the country
so used to be you started yet
do raid whose day this [ __ ] Friday I
still am flying into a town and doing
radio Wednesday Thursday and Friday
though they didn't give a [ __ ] who you
are
they had a lineup for you yeah Thursday
you gotta go do the driving at 5:00 and
you're like what the [ __ ] they take it
to a bar to do a live remote how
embarrassing is that
yeah you're the local opening out of the
grocery see ya have you been on TV right
then they walk away from me and [ __ ] you
know it's it's a [ __ ] Horror Show but
you said you said the ups and the downs
and I went home that night and I saw
about you know 93 93 96
like I was like Vietnam me it really
really was because it just wasn't a
commie see sometimes you
you know nobody drives don't open am I
gonna Testarossa right yeah I'm saying
nobody shows up an open mic Allah Butler
let's just let me out I'll be back in
ten minutes you know saying so but I had
no they show up the dope Mike they are
too but yeah I had a divorce going on I
had a messy child thing going on you
know the drugs didn't help and then I
was trying to economy I was pretty much
at war myself I was like a Palestinian I
was I was at war with everybody I'm
saying like I was just at war like I was
just so I think of those times like you
know I'm not being able to pay for my
lower rent like who can't pay for get me
couldn't pay it I used to always make it
for last month like the last week the
last three days of the month break I
made rent I'd have to steal a lot more
from Kmart return in a long month and
you know there was always something you
know and you know yeah you store you
like I thought that they were totally my
fourth year income had me like $8,000 I
knew one thing from the beginning Alonso
and that's what a lot of people don't
know and they refused to swallow the
pill there ain't no money
No and they'll tell you they'll tell you
to your face I know there's no money for
ten years and then they'll tell you
about money a week later you know no
money
no doesn't know maybe that lesson fee of
a doubt remember the air when I started
Thea said remember you go to college for
four years she said so any money you
make in your first four years it's a
bonus cuz anyone else would be paying to
go to school for that education then you
get your first job so it was like oh
okay
you know it was yeah that's real that's
how it is yeah you know I got I got
lucky and and it was definitely what you
said about getting the breaks that let
you know you're on the right track right
cuz I got new faces in Montreal back
when you used to get money out of new
faces and that was my first big paycheck
and that was when I could give up the
day job
I admired guys and I knew guys who were
bombing all the time and they kept
showing up me too and I admired that
because I would get laughs and when you
got laughs it made it easier to keep
showing up and I knew people literate
who were bombing all the time but they
kept showing and then they figured it
out you know and then like you said
years later ten years in now they're
there they're getting some I think some
people get to I'm some of a whole new up
some of them you know that I think for a
whole year in 92 I blew up yeah like I
know I didn't blow up I bomb every cent
pretty much in ninety twelve was a host
of a weekly show and I had to have five
new minutes of material every week it
was a homework assignment and I try my
hardest I really really went at it it
was the same people was $15 for a steak
and a baked potato and shrimp and it was
the same mooks and at that point I had
made it a goal to my job was just to
make him look up yeah
yeah I'm saying it wasn't even to make
him laugh if I could make him look up
from doing this you know cutting the
steak and putting their mouth I want in
here that's how I looked at in those
days because they weren't even laughing
at the feature see I was at one
China and and it was absolute luck right
place right time whatever I got an
education from the best because I did
the open mic at the Laugh Factory it's
my first year in so you started out here
I started I tell him I started in LA cuz
I didn't know I wasn't supposed to write
and Jamie hired me to be a doorman right
and he said you know if someone doesn't
show up you can do a spot right so I'm
at the Laugh Factory every night in
1993-94 and I'm watching Damon I'm
watching George Wallace I'm watching
George Lopez I'm watching Dahmer Eric
because this was the you know this was
back when they were it they're there
every night so I'm getting the master
class in how to do this [ __ ] right
George Wallace is showing up with a pad
every night working on new stuff you
know
you know Lopez the Wayans would roll in
deep there'd be 2 car falls away ins you
know and it all just come in working on
stuff so for me right I'm a new comic
I'm a year or two in I'm watching these
guys every night and I'm learning just
like oh you got to keep writing you got
to do this you got to do that you know
what I mean and and it was great and
then when phrase hired me fraser-smith
hired me to do to warm up for his radio
show so every Friday I had to do in new
five minutes so I had to write all the
time I had to pay attention to [ __ ] like
Ike because you had to what are you
gonna talk about I don't know what
happened this week what is there a new
new car in the showroom is that some
chicks as a TV show like what you know
what I mean but it was it was such a
great like it was just learning and it
was just learning and and like I say
sitting and you know George Lopez I
still remember this like this is 25
years ago Lopez told me this he said
listen man never give it up for who up
went up before you said like if I go up
before you they know who I am
so you make you and let them know who
you are
if you got five minutes there's no sense
spent in one minute telling them they
just saw George Lopez you know what a
lesson that was you know what I mean
that that was like oh okay because in
that moment you're on the same stage as
George Lopez as you know doc they used
to call him dr. Wallace right cuz that's
what he was he was a doctor you know no
way you know so yeah I was lucky in
those days but not everyone's that lucky
right at the same time I was a doorman
at Colorado wits end
yeah I like addy rule and what it gave
me was watching Acts they weren't the
best acts and I knew that they were what
the Comedy Works was getting right but I
was asking a lot of questions these were
older school Road comics and you know
took me 18 months to get on stage I got
out of prison February of [ __ ] 89 I
didn't get on stage till July of 91
that's how much of a [ __ ] I was you
know I mean I kept saying I'm gonna get
up then I saw dice in my head home yeah
I'm like this mother [ __ ] to him my
material is just [ __ ] I've been right
I'm telling mother [ __ ] I'm gonna get on
stage and I'm gonna write in my [ __ ] and
this is what I've been [ __ ] writing
and I saw dice on once I saw the I said
he pissed me off like I'm gonna hunt
this [ __ ] down and [ __ ] him up
he's doing my material and [ __ ] I didn't
have enough material but that's when I
thought in my head when I would walk
down the street I but what he was saying
so now I had to get pushed into it you
know and thank God when they put me out
it's [ __ ] crazy but when we when I
got home that night I didn't ride him
down I just thought about all the lows
all the nights that I came home they
used to be a comedy newspaper called
Just for Laughs yeah do you remember
that yes understand when you walked into
any comedy club and it was a monthly
publication put on a San Francisco but
if you went to the back section it had
all the comedy clubs and alphabetical
State outbreak horses father
last Alabama and I remember you know
having 20 minutes Alonso it being 1994
I'm doing comedy three years and it's
all I thought about like it was that
cocaine like you know get up in the
morning while I was pissing where am I
gonna do a spot tonight and I was
showering it was where am I gonna get
the money to do coke tonight and
sometimes it would mix it'd be a magical
gonna give me 40 that I could do 20
minutes then I get a free dinner and El
torito's yeah I love to read oh no yes
because I developed in Colorado but I
think about those times I thought about
that night I'll tell you what I came
close to crying by myself did I put
myself through all those nights like you
know on a Greyhound bus I was a regular
at the store and I was still ground yeah
because you cuz we had two four six
hundred a week 500 a week no hotel right
Greyhound bus in it we'll worry about it
when we get there where you gonna stay
worried about when we get there and sure
enough you get there and you're holding
out you do your little feature spot in
the [ __ ] and they're like waiting on
saying I don't know and there's usually
one [ __ ] was all about stage
time you know it was all about life
would I don't know nothing else I didn't
know man you know what I tell people I
don't watch TV from 1995 to 2002 they
died like I know nothing white people
told me about Seinfeld and friends I
know nothing yeah I didn't watch TV till
I moved out here and I had an audition
for NYPD Blue and I remember he used to
come on Tuesdays right day nights yeah
and how can I miss the [ __ ] black
show at The Comedy Store yeah if I'm
watching my PT buca's guy Torry would
put up up there early so I member
sitting in Washington YPD blue Jimmy
Smits his diet that's the episode you
ain't gonna put me uh when he was dying
a Kansan [ __ ] and I'm like I'm missing
[ __ ] stage time for this [ __ ] I had a
spot at the store but in those days it
was following Paul Mooney oh man 12:45
become good night so that's not a spot
that's a torture chamber
we were talking about this that night I
remember doing a spot at 1:15 in the
morning East remember to LA cabaret in
Encino little when I got here it lasted
six months at okay I did a spot it's
like 115 for two people I mean there's
two people left like yeah do your spot
and you did it right because what else
were you gonna do you had to do a spot
so that was a spot you got yeah it was
but again I think the passion that keeps
you going can also be the passion that
destroys you you know if it doesn't work
and the other thing was the other comics
right you could you you because we were
all doing it right so we were all like I
came up with like Johnny Sanchez and and
Willie Barcena and Chang and Ollie and
we were all doing this [ __ ] you know who
Shang was the king Shang had
one-nighters he had like a notebook full
of one-nighters everywhere across the
country be like Shang Wu I needed you
know I mean I'm in Houston cuz you
couldn't work in Houston there was
nothing for you in Houston but he had
some [ __ ] in Midland Odessa okay cuz
Houston was headliner territory you know
what I mean
but but the fact that we went through
that and I and I hung out with a lot of
the Latino comics Jeff Garcia and it's
enough I remember when fluffy bounced on
stage fluffy you spent booked at the
bicycle room yeah the bicycle casino and
y'all for the st. on Friday that's right
that [ __ ] dive and you look about
that and you were like who is this fat
kid nice shorts but because he even then
he had something that people just loved
him right they loved him and you would
just see it you know and and but anyway
you know we'd hang out right late at
night whatever after you do your spots
whatever you talk [ __ ] and you trade
notes and and I remember there used to
be what was it called moose
McGillicuddy's
in Marina del Rey and they had a comedy
contest and you win
it was either 50 or a hundred bucks it
was something like that
and we would take turns doing it because
we because like if Willie Barcena went
Willie was gonna win and if I went I was
gonna say what we would do is we're not
going up against either I you win it
this week and then I'll go next week you
know what I mean cuz but but we had that
and that was part of what kept us from
from giving up that because there was
always hope because someone got a job
right someone got a gig in and I know
I'm funnier than that [ __ ]
it's hard to explain but that was the
that was the life and that was how we
came up in it I was out seven nights a
week
absolutely I don't know what absolutely
what do you what are you gonna sit at
home
I was out seven nights a week with money
no money didn't matter I found spots
another thing I had is this was another
thing I was lucky I think that I had
probably I had pros tell me I was good
and I think that helped a lot
oh it means the world yeah I mean I'm
two years and then if a feature tells me
I do a good job it's it's amazing yeah
do you guys ever sit like because to me
it always blows my mind when I see
someone at your level doing a set and
then they're like working on new stuff I
like the Comedy Store love the laughs at
like to to think about working on
something at such a huge club it like I
can't even think about it like what do
you still have like the open mic mindset
or do you like what do you guys thing
about well I my favorite joke I don't
know about you joy my favorite joke is
always my newest it's always my newest
because that's the fun to work on but
what we have that you don't have yet is
we got the confidence because we know
[ __ ] works so we know we can get them so
you know what it's what you do after you
know you can make them laugh that's when
you really get into the [ __ ]
but it for such a journey first yet you
know they listen an artist journey a
musician a comedian it's a [ __ ]
journeying man and the journey is to
toughen your skin yep for later because
if you can't take those first five or
six years you don't want to deal with
what comes and later
you know this times you know and then
what would really call me chrome uptown
problems yeah yeah you know it's it's
it's but you got wallaby problem but you
got prepared because you toughen your
skin early on you you know Chloe isn't
when I walked into an audition I
couldn't sleep when I walked out of
there now I walk into an audition and
people ask me today sailor how'd you do
I am what are you talking about yeah if
I get it I gather if I don't exactly I
leave it they know there was there was
tough skin there was skin developed or
what he is
the other thing the difference with
comics is we got a practice in front of
people you know see I got a lot of
friends who are musicians and it's like
yeah we we don't really have studio time
right that's a comic that's the
difference we had to be bad in front of
people if you play the guitar you get to
practice the guitar in your basement and
your room and you and then you come out
when you're good at playing the guitar
as a comic it's like now you got to be
bad in front of people and then get good
in front of people
I'm really happy you said that Alonso
because it uh it made everything in my
life taste a little better it made me
remember what I did go through like I
almost got myself to tears on the drive
home going really I did all that [ __ ] I
really slept on park benches oh you know
I slept on a couch just for the name of
calmly you know I drove 16 hours to do
it for 14 hours to do a a guest set to
try to get work from knuckleheads and I
got the work than they want on a
business you know they gave me six weeks
of work and they went out of business
you know I mean I thought I think about
all of those listen man I can tell you
and you
how many times were we happy to drive
two hours for 25 bucks because he was
getting paid and two tacos use getting
pay and you got food and you were
getting paid and people you know like
it's funny to be like people are mention
a town in California there's nowhere I
haven't been there like Oh Hemet they
said it's like yeah well you're kidding
I came up in LA I've done every town
Eureka Hemet what it whatever Visalia
you know all of these places yeah yeah
yeah of course cuz whatever you had to
write you had to drive and doing every
night you are on the five South yeah all
I know is going to five said all the
time train Rudy Jeff oh man uh Rudy Jeff
the other kid there was like six or
seven Mexicans and these [ __ ]
put us to work on a daily week I told I
just did I thanked them [ __ ] every day
I think I just did Toys for Tots for
Rudy Sunday night and I was telling the
friend you are not an LA comic if you
haven't done a Rudy Marino game yeah and
you haven't done one of Rudy's remember
Rudy used to have all those rooms entry
level [ __ ] you think you'd be $20 a show
Friday and Saturday oh man I was there
the night Marilyn got into the riot
there was a riot yeah yeah what happened
Rudy I don't know Rudy was man Rudy's
and you know and and you know these are
the guys right so people they don't know
him they don't know who he is but he's
an icon amongst comics I can't
I love Howie I just have regular balls
he's always [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on
Facebook so he drives me crazy and had
himself in a few weeks ago cuz he kept
sending me a fly like no words just a
fly just [ __ ] flying for Rudy do you
think I'll ever have you to come down
one night not really really [ __ ] liar
but you know I think of all those nights
like being broke
going the Commerce Casino and Rudy
giving you a hundred hundred bucks for
the Commerce Casino Thursday night run
in the back at Chinese food they're
saying that really the Chinese yeah but
I still let me go on accomplished casino
he would put out toys yeah on the table
I wouldn't even put him in my pocket I
just keep taking the outside show them
and then in between sets when he was up
on stage I go ruddy really Rudy I just
keep saying Rudy I used to love I'm
trying to think where was I oh I did
this bar gig that's called the federal
bar sin
Long Beach and it was cool I did a few
weeks ago there was a big motorcycle
show so it's doing this show after the
motorcycle show and a bunch of bike
friends came down but anyway they were
like you gotta be off stage at 9:30
because dancin starts at 10:00 and I was
like oh [ __ ] I ain't done one of these
in a long time remember us remember that
you had to be offstage cuz the DJ the
people would be lined up for the DJ and
you had to have you I used to have to
follow a line dancing class and Denver
on Sunday nights that turned into a
pretty good room yeah but you had to
wait for the lion dancers to get out all
right you gotta remember 92 that was
achy breaky yeah hell yeah
everybody was doing achy breaky line
dancing classes on a Sunday [ __ ]
night a hundred fat country woman with
boots on and one blackjack 99 white one
black Jake that's I'm coming and yeah no
thank you for enlightening me last
listen to early part of your comedy
career right
it's annoying people yeah right you're
doing comedy did the noise people you
going to their local bar doing a comedy
night that they don't know about right
you're in the back of a bookstore that
people want peace and quiet I did a bike
shop to exist there you go it your your
big is where can I go annoy people in
this comedy a Mehta med used to have a
gig in a I think it was at a Cuban
restaurant in West Ella it was a
restaurant you know and you'd you'd
literally like if poor people came to
eat dinner but we're gonna bug you for
the next 45 paramore how they do that in
the valley yeah there's a restaurant up
here that does know this beef wheat and
dinner and you're going up these people
even know it's common that's right
that's your job your job they came to
talk and you're asking [ __ ] questions
if you're out of town your job
it's we used to do this woman Victoria
do Schaaf she'd always get gigs in these
hotels who is Victoria Victoria well
heard I think it was her dad her dad was
a big-time club guy he died there Lance
or something yeah she died of cancer
father what was the name of it
what was the Latin has seen a Latin
casino right right and and she was great
she but we would do a way out of cancer
yeah we would do Wednesday night at the
Holiday Inn body Airport by LAX and
every Wednesday there was like a German
tour group that stayed at the hotel so
half the people at the bar did not speak
English they were German and we were
there every Wednesday night shang used
to I think I met Shang at that gig but
but you know that's that's the work
right so so this is what I was talking
about and and at the time I didn't know
anything was wrong with that because I
got on stage you know but there were
times man where I took hits and and for
me I'll tell you the hardest part for me
was def jam crowds the hardcore black
crowds because I'm a black comic but I'm
not that black comic right I'm gonna
come from a different place and those
crowds used to I would get destroyed I
would get destroyed food I I did a place
called
my brother's favorite story in my career
Manhattan proper in Queens where I grew
up they didn't just boo me off the stage
they booed me out to the building onto
Linden Boulevard but the moment that the
one I remember was it was at the
Normandy casino in LA right and and I
was getting booed and heckled and this
guy was hitting me with prison heckles
that I don't even know what the [ __ ] he
was talking about right and speedy I
don't know if your new speedy Haiti what
happened to him
I don't know but speedy came up to me he
said yo man don't worry about this [ __ ]
he said you working in Hollywood already
he's it these [ __ ] would kill
to get to Hollywood he said don't worry
about them you ain't gonna gain nothing
by getting them they're following you
and and Cedric the Entertainer said was
another one who back in that day he was
like you know you do you don't worry
about this [ __ ] you do you and and this
is getting back to what we were talking
about when a pro says that to you this
I'm two years in three years in right
and and my own people you know I mean
I'm like the [ __ ] am i doing yeah
and but but they were the ones who were
like do you do you man you just don't
worry about it just keep working keep
working and don't don't try to be
something you're not
don't try to be you know something this
you know I grew up in I grew up in
Queens I grew up in the Saint Albans
Queens working class black neighborhood
or whatever they said so don't try to
come from into it because you ain't
familiar right you des not you so so
don't try to be that and and it worked
and then and my heroes were guys like
Franklin enjoy
Yeah right people don't even remember
Franklin enjoy I should met him let the
commies throw like a mug and Franklin
and I was his legend Franklin as I was
and he was my Selman car-washing yeah
yeah that's what everyone remembers but
his stand-up
you know was he was brilliant and so so
that that helped me a lot but those were
two down times man I I remember doing a
set after I went to the black Expo and I
went up somewhere in LA I don't remember
where black Club and I was trying to
make fun of the black Expo and they
wasn't having it
they wasn't having that [ __ ] for a
minute and those were the days that like
I said if it wasn't for the fact that I
got up again you know the next day or
two days later those that those that's
how you build a joker what do you
remember more your crushes are your
bombings uh bombing oh I [ __ ] love
them yeah
Bonnell them close to my heart well now
you now I don't know about you I laugh
when I bomb I laugh too because I'm like
I got out of the way I'm like I'm you
know what I think is just like how could
I be that wrong yeah I thought this [ __ ]
was funny how could I've been doing this
[ __ ] for 2060 how could I have missed by
that much you go home I still remember
getting the call and crying oh going
this is my last month your life robbed
your life is worthless this is the last
time I'm gonna spot the Comedy Store I'm
gonna bomb in front of Mitch he just
walking right to my car go well it looks
like I'm going back to stealing I dated
this chick and she had been married to a
comic and she literally said to me she
said you know I could fall in love with
you she said but I can't do it again
she's I can't do another comic it's too
hard with you guys your [ __ ] life is
just it takes a special woman but but
but what what part of it would you trade
me right now yeah what part of the road
to be Joey Coco Diaz today you know I'm
saying what part of the past 20 25
whatever would you trade right you can't
because this times I'm on stage now and
I can actually feel myself getting
laughter and I could see my mind going
back
94 and going the reason why I'm getting
this laughter is because that nine that
bar eight that bag of dick man right
when I'm onstage this is happening to me
and I'm still cracking jokes but my mind
has taken me they're going the reason
why I'm doing so well tonight is because
of that particular 1997 in Bremerton
Washington right thank God I'm still and
then well you talked about it earlier
when you doing the interview right you
can talk to the interview now because
you were on k KJ a Y in Ames Iowa it's
Tuesday morning on the laughing clown
and we got Joey cocoa Diaz and you you
did that art of that interview so when
you sit on the couch it to tonight's
show you like I got this right
everything we did the lesson came up
later every every shitty one night every
time the microphone didn't work and now
you got a problem and a problem I've
worked without a mic before lights went
out all right we got again let's go
right cuz we cuz you've done you you
know we've done that [ __ ] right you or
or you know you need time to I got to
get my head right well nah man cuz the
Greyhound stopped at 7:00 and the show
stopped at 7:15 I literally hit this
stage on a dead run i still remember
changing in a cab from Dulles Airport on
the phone with the host minutes and I'm
changing in the [ __ ] cab from Dulles
to Tyson's Corner Virginia the guy had a
hotel room on Fridays and Saturdays it
was the Friday after Thanksgiving I get
to the airport holes at the airport
go wait and lit already my boy joins a
little puff and I see him at the airport
ease guys come over have a drink we've
started drinking uncle George I got to
leave
you're delayed - so I was delay with joy
I think I said we got to the April at 7
I think I finally took off and like [ __ ]
my 11 I got the DC at like 848 I then
guess what steel he won that was on the
[ __ ] plane I had a little more first
I gotta get him up he's gotta walk
through steps you gotta get the dog and
ain't on the blind guys does he bring us
like three blind guys with so that's
another half hour and I'm running late
the Tyson's Corner and Stevie one they
gotta be on this [ __ ] flying
ain't that a [ __ ] so all those things
yeah like we're not even thinking there
was that night there was no looking at
your notes right it was 45 minutes are
going up there and I hope I remember
whatever the [ __ ] is on the plane yeah
you're focused you're landing you're not
[ __ ] you're focused on landing I'm
happy you stopped by what are we gonna
do with the Clippers this man talk to me
what are the Clippers gonna do this year
okay this is my thing I'm a clipper fan
I'm Joey
I want the second round cuz we ain't
been to the second round that's all you
want I will this year I want the second
round I worry about the finals next year
this year I want the second round I got
no problem with load management on Kauai
he knows what he's doing if he says he
ain't playing tonight I don't care
because come April and May
he's MVP Paul George is even better than
I thought so I see the Clippers going
deep my only problem is [ __ ] LeBron
who's on a mission and I knew LeBron was
gonna be great this season because he
had the whole summer off I didn't know
he was gonna be the best point guard in
the NBA right LeBrons going crazy so
we'll see but uh you know I'm a man you
know I'm there and imma keep calling you
I got I hit you up for game I love you
got [ __ ] to do I follow you in and out
of man laughing the only [ __ ]
gets delayed every week by an airline
every week guys man American Airlines
Monday you're at war with some American
Airlines has my American Airlines has
downgraded me twice see the look on your
face see you didn't see people don't
even know that you
can get downgraded yes Joey downgraded
as in I paid for business and they're
like look you want to go back to coach
twice I've been downgraded Joey they
give you money man but yeah they give
you a $300 voucher the [ __ ] is that
yes downgraded always working always
doing radio you're hustling and you were
the true [ __ ] I still love it man know
that I still love it I had such a good
time here that night because I watched
you up there after me talking and I'm
like that's a problem man either say
[ __ ] he went up there and he's having a
good [ __ ] time okay on the web to her
you text me and I was like see this is
what I'm talking about this is what I'm
talking about the love and this is what
I was talking about about comics right
about how we tell you and me might see
each other five times a year but it's
always good know it's always always good
and sometimes just some [ __ ] happens and
I'm like oh I got a text Joey about this
Joey's gonna love this or vice versa
the Clippers won again texted me Wendy
was find him when they signed him he
gave me a shout-out he said Alonzo been
there is day one this is what I'm
talking about this guy was dead in the
universe took a [ __ ] fan and I was so
happy for you Thank You Man and then I
bumped into Eric Griffin yeah he got rid
of his ticket so he bought him back boy
yeah we got I got that TV money no long
you know yeah he bought it he bought
didn't bought him back any dates you
wanted from my whitey my uh I got this
weekend coming up La Jolla Comedy Store
and then the weekend of the 21st I'm at
Grand Rapids dr. grins beautiful yeah oh
my favorite yeah dr. Greene hello ah the
trends for me yeah yeah up under [ __ ]
people up on the third floor they good
oh there's a good [ __ ] dude third
floor hey I'm in New York this week
tickets a god
Boston's gone right now all I got
available for you [ __ ] is
December 21st
triple Christmas Runkle Joey nice the
Saturday before nice early show 7:30 you
go to your cousin's house at 9:30 and
snort coke or whatever the [ __ ] you do
uncle and that's that's that Ilan's I
want to thank you man I love you coming
by thank you today so good to be back in
the church giving us some love real
quick the holidays are coming you want
to looking for some give some people I
got an amazing unconventional gift for
you give anybody in your life you look
at your mom and go I wonder what my mom
has asked for smell like everybody has
an ass everybody deserves the gift of
tushy tushy is a portable bidet that
sprays directly into you ass and removes
all this [ __ ] completely so you're not
sitting there [ __ ] stinking up
everything but there's a common in the
rest of the world they save you money on
toilet paper and do you want clogged
toilet so she sprays your ass with fresh
water it's not toilet water because she
connects to a water supply behind your
toilet to spray your dirty ass clean
with fresh water it's the same water you
brush it deep with wet wipes are worse
than toilet paper that terrible free
environment they cause anal fissures you
don't want any officious listen to me
I've been with tushy for three years
they got a 60 day guarantee who gives a
[ __ ] I'm 300 pounds and that tushy has
been clinging my ass now for three
[ __ ] years lead to they started $79
all right this is the gift that is
[ __ ] tremendous anybody who you give
it this and I love it go - hello - she
calm right now press in church and get
10% off and do me a favor look at her
she's laying this product with her she
ottoman helps you get everything out
again go - hello - she calm press in
church and get 10% off your order
like I told you earlier you got one
month before the new year
athletic greens will help you get there
if you're not starting a day off with a
blast of vitamins you already lost the
war you might as well go back to bed but
if you want to feel tip-top Magoo let
athletic greens do it with dirty
in one scoop you get 75 essential
vitamins minerals prebiotics probiotics
digestive enzymes
raus superfoods mushrooms and whole
foods they got everything normal pill
bottles are trying to choke down a dozen
apples it's all in there and they make
it easy to use with travel packs when
I'm on the road boom a little athletic
greens like a little daily insurance
policy I drink this and I can have a
little fun plus I could stay on the road
because I'm healthy
this helps with my immunity you
understand me
so you can relax because all their
ingredients are plant-based if you're on
keto gluten-free no chemicals no
artificial flavors no artificial
preservatives no sweetness no added
sugar no GMOs listen this has been older
besides no yeast peanuts or animal
products guys you need to take care of
yourself it's 2020 and that's why I
recommend supplements to everybody it's
just that easy just add cold water and
shake it up you can take that banana and
shut up your ass what are you waiting
for
go do me a favor right now go to
athletic greens right now press in
church I'm gonna get your special offer
twenty travel packs valued at $79 with
your first purchase jump all grew
athletic greens calm slash Church and
get your travel packs today athletic
greens are tremendous again the holidays
are common anybody wants to get their
dick sucked but your dick smells like a
billy goat
why because you got a [ __ ] you got
like like Julius Erving afro around your
[ __ ] dick and it [ __ ] sweats so
it's over you're looking for a gift
manscaped you like Joey what's manscape
it's the only tool you need to shave
your balls and the area around your
[ __ ] love fold it's called a
lawnmower 2.0 for a reason they threw
away the 1.0 and upgraded their trimmer
with a skin safe technology for your
mumbles in the back that means it won't
Nick or snag your sack plus it's perfect
for travel easy to charge and you can
manscape with one [ __ ] hand and if
this is the first time you could sit in
manscaping they got a deal for you
you ready Alonso they have the perfect
[ __ ] package comes at the
lawnmower and a safety razor plus a crop
preserve especially formulated deodorant
so you balls don't stink I'm wearing it
right now
and the Reviver spritz that tones and
refreshes your junk to keep your cool
let's say you're an old man you got
wrinkles on your nutsack you spray the
Reviver I'm there forget about it
it looks like [ __ ] a shaved head
listen please head nice and smooth with
the perfect package your pouch will be
powdered and your poll will be perfected
what are you waiting for do me a favor
right now today the church gets 20% off
your first order when you use promo code
church at manscape calm excuse me and if
you order the perfect package they also
throw in a free travel bag when you use
the code Church CH you are CH that's
manscape calm use promo code church and
get 20% off your order manscape
precision tools
throw the family jewels I want to thank
manscape
I want to thank hello tushy calm and I
want to thank athletic greens we're
putting this podcast podcast together
but I want to thank Alonzo Bodden for
being the star of it today my brother
you always welcome on here I love you
Joey
thank you what you're doing you too
messy to live great to reminisce great
to move forward whatever listen I just
want you really let these young comics
know that they're running a [ __ ]
charity out here you're gonna have to
give you know when you burn the fire
they take ass from your skin they put on
your face the same thing it's the grind
baby it's your love I cry [ __ ] love
the grunt it's all about the grind if
you angling grind try tennis don't take
you over there I love you mother [ __ ]
stay black I'll see you in New York and
in Boston Saturday night kick this
[ __ ] melee